shift gears way from the one you're
looking at me like that because I know I
can't stick this one the creepy houses
of America I don't know
New Orleans is it New Orleans yeah
people looked at like there's flashes of
GPS coordinates and you're like oh I
know that yeah I can smell Creole yeah
Resident Evil 7 all right mm-hmm
seven that way for you guys I think
biohazard that sounds good by us yeah
present evil 7 : biohazard did you see
the reveal the Japanese reveal because
if there's visible Joe hazards Resident
Evil 7 it is but in order to incorporate
the 7 they put it in the Z oh that's
wonderful yeah it works either way
yeah I don't know which one they started
with they either did the North American
or like all right we got it I got the
Japanese [ __ ] it's like or if it's the
other way around it's like whoever made
the logo for evolve was just like we got
it is it the claw no it's the one where
it's the 5v one writing the name I did
not know about that until ready why it's
real good
that's good yeah let's talk about it I
played the demo after e3 like last week
I was home for one day and I glued it
off the played it you played as well yep
you played it all I've not looked at
hear about ru Resident Evil 5 not really
okay I did you play PT I did okay loved
it that's interesting cuz that's kind of
like the the other driver that you know
this is a weird side until for the room
kind of thing going on as well yeah and
what did you think like first of all I
liked it I came away from it pretty
positive there are a few problems with
it but for the purpose of a demo that it
won't actually be part of the main game
much like PT was I think that's another
parallel I'm excited for it as a
Resident Evil is one of my favorite
series alongside like Zelda it's one of
the ones I will I haven't been happy
with in a long time but I'm really
excited for hopefully this kind of
return to form even though it's very
different person resin evil which is new
yeah so that's that that's one of a
couple of differences we have here right
so the first one is we don't know what
like theme it's going to be we've we've
you know that there's a very sort of
spooky the be movie / poltergeist II
feel to this thing
they've since come out and said that
it's not going to have the sort of the
the ghost-like elements there's a quote
here from Capcom I think you can look at
the trailer of the demo and get that
impression but don't worry we haven't
just thrown out Resident Evil as it
exists and turned it into a ghost story
it will all make sense in the end that
quote coming out of Koshi
and knock knock in inchi i don't know i
should've looked that up before we
started the show and from capcom unity
from their internal communications blog
there i know it's frustrating holding
back on what we can show fans but this
is really the best way to let you enjoy
the game to the fullest when it comes
out we just have a trailer and a demo at
the moment but watch this space in the
coming months and we hope to look
forward we hope you look forward to the
game we're going to do our best to make
it the best game we can so what's the
premise of this demo again I think I've
heard like it's you know you waltz into
this room and kind of unravel this seems
like outlets at last a little like pick
up tapes and stuff there's a kind of a
fan footage element to it where you were
playing almost like two different time
periods within the same house yeah and
you essentially you play you wake up in
this place and start exploring the house
and it's a it's a pretty short sort of
puzzle to try and get at it a house and
then there's a part where it cuts -
previously on where you put in the video
tape right there that's what it is yeah
and then you go back to the cameraman
it's like this news crew it's like this
CT rancor who does like these haunted
house experts yeah exactly and so it's
kind of like yeah 1408 john cusack kind
of breaking into this place and and you
know trying to show off find all the
poltergeist in there and then it all
goes awry so you play it yeah from like
either two different perspectives or
from the same perspective to different
time zones or whatever and but it's
similar to PT in that there is a bunch
of like weird little I don't know like
different ways to get around this but
didn't seem like there was that much in
terms of that like it seemed like I
don't think anyone's figured out the
reason for the dummy finger yet right
there are two definite endings once
upstairs once the back door right oh I
didn't get the ops tears one then I do
the back door first as well and then
first yeah and you the W finger people
think there might be another ending they
haven't found but did the other dummy
finger is like you find it like almost
immediately on this like dresser in the
hallway right people thought maybe you
smudged the TV screen
something with it but it might just be
like the axe is therefore no reason
that's just okay put that in there
Courtney is someone that Capcom told me
they put that in there just to show
there will be combat they did that
Capcom unity post effort being like
there's gonna be combat in this game
they're gonna be there's herbs so
there's survival elements ok it's not
just this expert exploration this wasn't
me and meant to like set the tone and
show that they're kind of going back to
horror roots as a most like six is all
out QuickTime event action which is no
QuickTime event in this at all yeah I
mean even five you could say was was a
kind of action game I mean for was the
turning point yes even to look back at
like three nemesis compared to one and
two three was the same style it was
those pre-rendered backgrounds
third-person take controls but you still
would the nemesis chasing the whole time
you had a lot of little more ammo is
more of a little more of an action
horror game for of course like for good
reason there was a awesome game like
even even - to a certain extent did have
the sort of you know ammunition scare
CDs stuff of Resident Evil 1 but there
what it was like the sort of Tomb Raider
2 - Tomb Raider one where there was a
lot more combat and sure it wasn't the
first game yeah so I guess like the main
question I want to ask you is just
looking at this and sort of projecting
maybe towards Resident Evil 7 is were
you scared
playing this I don't think I was so I
played outlast 2 again at e3 which I'm
really excited to that game that scared
me meri and I played it for the first
time at PAX East and then that was it
was the same demo both times but that
game actually is nailing that tone but
again that's part it's tough to say
because the out last time we played is
part of the game whereas this isn't so
from this there's a couple parts here
that I was pretty freaked out it was
nothing huge
like it wasn't Pt levels but yeah PT's I
mean like Pte is a whole like
psychological kind of trauma thing like
familial disintegration that a resonable
7 sort of seems to be touching on the
only tie to resin evil you see in the
whole game if you have the upstairs
ending you see a picture with a
helicopter with the umbrella your kid
corporation logo on it so they say like
are they watching us or something cuz
right now we don't know this is a new
character it's a Clancy Jarvis if I'm
not mistaken wops yeah
which isn't as bad as do you can st.
John from days gone but it's still a
weird name yeah I don't know I have a
similar thing where I lost one not
played any of our last two if they don't
last one and that's a scary game
the uneasier games terrify the crap out
of me I'm Petey got to me as well and
this was getting there it was like where
those games like hit the nines like this
got to be seven and like was threatening
eight but I never really sort of got
into that like there was certain parts
that like made me literally like close
up and shiver that like very in sort of
specific moments and Bush there was
never like the sort of overall feeling
of dread and fear and like I didn't have
and I faded at nighttime in a dark room
oh yeah I play in the middle the office
before we talked about it on dead air to
plug yeah absolutely
dead air at the horror podcast we spoke
about it we have someone coming on this
week from Capcom to talk about like the
process leading up to the reveal because
the secrecy behind it was crazy but
that's another conversation but I don't
know like for similarities with Petey I
get the comparison they're both demos
they're not part of the main game
they're both for that first-person kind
of like the outlast feel because that
last two like it was underrated at e3 I
think that Mary can attest I think she
liked the demo maybe not as much as I
did but you know like resin evil the
puzzles in this game is there still
puzzles yeah in that you're going to one
part of the house and you're finding
like this key that's gonna open this
what you're gonna find a VHS tape what
you play which you go back in time and
find a trapdoor in the past that you
come back to the present and you're like
oh [ __ ] this will yeah
the puzzles here are a little more
doable than Petey's Petey's really like
tough like you weren't you one of the
people that played it for like 12 hours
straight
like midnight and we said can't do it
sorry and then I don't even know if we
ever figured out what or how to beat it
if like start speaking individuals or
speaking but my actually my question is
like was it not scary because there
wasn't a threat and this Resident Evil
Deborah was was there not someone
chasing you it's like all these games
have an underlying line like you die you
can die based on how well you can hide
how well you can avoid the threat in the
house is there never I thought I saw
jump scares in the demo trailer yeah
there was an ending in the trailer when
you finally see what's in that looks
like that's why right like what's you're
scared by the atmosphere but if there's
no looming dude with a knife person like
that
I wondered like
I bet that all goes out the window if
you played in virtual reality I bet it's
[ __ ] terrifying
well I bet it's like if they did it
right from what I heard they didn't do
it that well oh really
I didn't Scott did I just member someone
was saying that when you crouch in the
VR demo it doesn't show the transition
you just snap to a crowd some people oh
my god but that's also like remains to
be seen how that will work
yeah that's gonna make a good gift all
right to talk about it in relation to
other than evil I'm excited for it don't
get me wrong uh January 24th on
PlayStation 4 it is actually coming out
on Xbox one and Windows as well Hodgins
I thought it was a ps4 exclusive for the
longest time PlayStation VR they could
play its start to finish but Capcom has
another Titan exclusive Xbox one Dead
Rising 4 they also announced at the show
that's true yeah strategic of them
different technology I don't know on the
the zombie think yeah I guess we'll have
to win see I'm connected it is to resi 7
and part of me wonders if they spend all
this time making this demo and it's
being Capcom and their current like form
in 2016 already I think this looks ripe
for slipping like January 24th for a
game we've seen nothing of and we still
don't really know what the full game
looks like yeah I don't know what yeah
fingers crossed
let's see some more of Resident Evil 7
biohazard let us know in the comments if
you're excited for this yeah and we'll
have more coverage of that on game over
the coming months provided Capcom starts
better
you